- He's selling nuts too.
He's selling nuts, this guy.
I told him, this is my market.
♪ I'm the Naked Cowboy ♪
♪ Keep it revolving ♪
(alarm clock beeping)
(slide guitar music)
I generally get up around
seven, when I sleep well.
First thing I do, I walk
straight to the kitchen,
I put the coffee in the microwave.
I'm writing a journal every day,
and my journals, to me, are everything.
You know, it's kind of
like you're just constantly
shooting for the stars,
looking at the big picture,
and you're basically, your life
follows the patter of your thoughts.
Life is tough.
It's hard to stay motivated, especially
if you're really keeping yourself moving.
People always say: do you work out?
And I'm always like nope, it's a gift.
Pizza, beer, and cigarettes,
that's all you need.
I'm driven to succeed, to get publicity,
to get numbers, to be seen,
and to share, motivate,
inspire, influence,
and impact everyone.
After about an hour,
sometimes two hours of that,
I take a shower, basically
just get ready for work.
(water splashing)
Most people don't know
I have the fastest shave in the east.
Well I have a huge underwear collection.
My wife is constantly
putting 'em on boards,
painting 'em, and I'm constantly
getting a fresh supply of mediums.
When they're brand-new, it's
like putting on a new suit.
You're like, ah, I feel confident today!
(light guitar music)
Towards the end of high
school, I would imagine,
somebody told me about this
book, "Unlimited Power".
Up to that point, I was a crazy, wild kid,
in trouble all the time,
going to the courthouse for,
you name it, 50 different
juvenile misconduct stuff.
I'm reading the book and this guy says
I could be anything I
want, I could be rich,
successful and everything else.
Somebody actually, instead of
saying I can't do something,
said I could do something.
I was trying to be a country singer,
a model, an actor, or a body-builder.
When I went to Venice
Beach, California, 1998,
to shoot for Playgirl magazine,
(whistling)
I went and played
on the beach in a cowboy
outfit, with my clothes,
was ignored the entire day.
The photographer who was shooting me naked
said why don't you play in your underwear.
I knew when I got in my underwear
and did it, and nobody came over, I knew
it right then and there.
So that was, you know,
the birth of Naked Cowboy,
if you will.
I went back to Cincinnati, my hometown,
did the same thing I did at Venice Beach,
I got in my underwear and boots and hat
in the parking garage,
came out and played.
People went crazy, took pictures,
and then the police arrested me
and I got like a $69, or
something like that, citation.
But I got on the morning
show the next day.
(laughing)
♪ Well I'm the Naked Cowboy ♪
Sorry to interrupt you.
- Oh, we like it.
- So I paid $69 and I'm on TV,
and I'm talking about how I'm
gonna be the most celebrated
entertainer of all time,
I'm advertising Naked Cowboy.
I basically went from Cincinnati
all the way to Key West, Florida,
and they got the news
almost in every city.
I call the police and the news.
How could I not?
And then a friend suggested going east,
'cause he said I could get
arrested every two or three hours
instead of every 10 or 12 hours.
The cities are closer together.
I went east for that reason.
Happened to go to New York,
happened to fall into Times Square,
got a cheap hotel and came
back for the second day.
Two days became 16 years.
My goal was never to
be a street performer,
and get a dollar and
a dollar and a dollar.
Ultimately, that's what it's come to.
But the whole point was,
get very successful,
create a brand, and
sell products worldwide,
and get checks in the mail
for the rest of my life.
(light acoustic guitar music)
Almost 18 years, nearly every single day.
My routine of going in and everything,
I'd like to say it gets
easier all the time,
but the winter's a tough time
of year for a naked cowboy.
If it's 20 degrees, like it's been lately,
you're looking at 30 minutes,
two hours in a garage,
30 minutes, when I come
out of the cold especially,
your body's all tight and it's tense.
Working out is a stress reliever,
and it just warms you up.
(light acoustic guitar music)
(tuning guitar)
(light guitar strumming)
♪ Well I started off in New York City ♪
♪ Playing a song or two ♪
♪ All my gigs cut early ♪
♪ And I didn't know what to do ♪
♪ I tried country, rock ♪
♪ Even blues ♪
♪ Still my plans, they fell through ♪
♪ So I hitched a plane to Venice Beach ♪
♪ In jeans and boots ♪
♪ Played for seven hours ♪
♪ Barely made a buck or two ♪
♪ I was ignored, even booed ♪
♪ So I dropped my 501 blue ♪
Round two!
♪ Now I'm the Naked Cowboy ♪
♪ Keepin' it real for you ♪
♪ I'm the Naked Cowboy ♪
♪ You gotta do what you gotta do ♪
♪ Now I'm the nude sensation ♪
♪ Yeah, does any do ♪
♪ Swinging my but in my undies and I ♪
♪ Play the same damn tune ♪
♪ When I'm on the chalks ♪
♪ The TV news ♪
♪ Doing best, what I do ♪
Round three!
♪ I'm the Naked Cowboy ♪
♪ Keepin' it real for you ♪
♪ You gotta do what you gotta do ♪
I do about, I would say
anywhere from 60 to $100 an hour,
no matter what.
You know, everybody thinks
I'm a multi-millionaire
because I'm so well known, so famous.
I literally was out there
for like three years,
and never even took a dollar.
Time Life, they did a piece explaining
how I made $150,000 a year,
and that's about more accurate these days,
but that's working almost every day,
with rent at $2,000, my car,
exclusively for business,
at $1,000 a month, car
insurance, health insurance,
parking's almost $1,000
in the city, where I park.
So making $150,000 in revenue,
I'm also spending like $80,000.
Then I got a deal with
Blue Island Oyster Company,
now this is what we're really looking for.
And we have Naked Cowboy Oysters
that are sold in over 700
restaurants in the United States.
I've gotten checks as
much as $20,000 a month.
Naked Cowboy Wines, we
just signed this deal,
in Hood River, Oregon.
When I decided to get
into the wine business,
I knew only one company would
fit the bill: Naked Winery.
We have Naked Cowboy Hot Sauce,
I also do personal
appearances at $1,000 an hour
in the city, $10,000 out
of the city for a day.
Just did Germany for Volkswagen.
Not bad for an honest day's living.
Do I think I'll retire?
Well at this point in my
life, I just turned 47,
I think I could be old and do it.
It's more about being funny.
It would be funny no matter what.
My goal has always been
to get rich and famous,
so until I get rich, I'm not quitting,
that's for sure.
(light acoustic guitar music)
(whisking)
(squeaking)